[Music]
I'm kind of getting some vibes right now
are you feeling Eve I have no idea what
you mean what's the latest you can tell
us about life sighs I can tell you that
we are working on an amazing script I've
been hitting up miss Lindsay Lohan and
her dm's like yo you at you in boo and I
think she is excited to come back so has
she said yes yeah pretty much
did you Lindsay I think she did imagine
that these two characters are all these
years later though the weird thing is
Eve's got a stuck in time so she's gonna
be a little older but hopefully not
looking that much older
whereas when Lindsay started me she was
that little ten-year-old girl now she's
a woman so we have to evolve that and
figure out who she is today when you
first made that movie did you ever think
that all these years later fans would be
like desperately wanting you to do it
again not at all in fact I turned down
life-sized 205 set that personally 15
years ago really so this was already in
the works and you're like uh I turned it
down I was done because I thought you'll
just have to hear about this later
in a book coming to a bookstore near you
in 2018 so many amazing things going on
right now and I've got to tell you this
has been the best season of America's
Got Talent cuz you've been such a great
support system when people get kicked
off the show you're the first person
that they see what has that been like
for you you know it's it's just like the
mom skills come out you know it's like
I'm hugging I'm stopping tears sometimes
you don't see and then edit but I'm like
taking my shirt and stopping or if kids
are crying you know we don't let me show
that on TV but if a kid is crying I'm
getting them to chant everybody messes
up everybody messes up everybody messes
up this just makes this better and we're
gonna come back later we're gonna do
good you know so it's just constant love
and affection love that and you're a
momma yourself now - what does that been
like for you
yeah I'm in heaven with my little
pumpkin yeah my heart is on the outside
and he walks around
my heart it's been the most surprising
aspect of motherhood that you've
discovered I don't know just how you can
love something so much almost and you
just like you want to wake this being up
in the middle of the night to cuddle
with it but know that you shouldn't yes
balancing motherhood with America's Next
Top Model with America's Got Talent what
does that been like for you
um actually because I do things in
chunks I'm trying to do things in chunks
now and not have them overlap so that
helps
it's like America's Got Talent then we
take a break then I go teach at Stanford
then I take a break then I do Top Model
then I take a break back to America's
Got Talent
you know so chunks as opposed to layers
[Music]
you